W
E V. WADLPESAC CE
EN WHITMER FOR HER JOBN .
TSTATE , Y WEEKENLIVE
STOCK COMPETNS.
WATCH HIS GRANDDAUGHTER ABBY
SHOW HER PIGS. HERE LABOR DAEKEE
RNER.
I WANT WHAT'S BEST
COY POLITICIANS. RWHT
>>E WIFE DA IS
UNDECITO
REP
WARYN.
>> ABORTIOUR
VOTEORE?
ABORTIONTE FOR HER. WHATTUDOR DT
>> Reporter: SO FA OF WHAT
S FROM DEMOCRATIC ADS.OR
>> ARE YOU FORHE EXEMPTIONS PE ?
>> I AM NOT.CE THE
REPUBLICANRIMARY AUGUS KEPT A O
THAIGN
HER DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT,
WHITMER NOT SO
MICHIGAN
CONTTO BE A PRO-CHOICE
STATE IS BECAUSE OF MYO ANMY LA
MIN FROM  ETURNEFILED A LAWSUI A
THE STATE SUPREME COURT
N WHETHER AN AIOHAT DREW NEARLY
600,000 VALID SIURES WILALLOT I
>> THE VASF THLE IN THE STATE S
WOMAN TO BE ABLE TO MAKE HER OWN
DECISION.  Reporter: IT'S A MOT
ROUND TABLE.
>> PEOPL THE MY MOM WILL BE PUS
RIGHTS. THEIR REPRODUCTIVE
>> I COULD NOTAVT
BETTER MYSELF.
eporter: NOT EVERYONAGREES.
>>'T THIHEION
IS A BIG MICGA>> Reporte A A
TUDOPPORTER, WASESTING OUTSI WH
EVENT.
CARE ABOU
>> RorHITMERKETS HAVE BEEN SNG.
TOUTED JOB CREAT
S HEADN.H OF AISE STRUGGLING T
ODBLE.
RELIEF. orter: TOR  OORN MONTH L
INTERVIEW.
HER CAMPAIGN WOULDN'T SHAR
THE STATE OFICteED GREEDOM
YOUNGKIN WIS
ATIGNING
ON THE CULTURAL DIVIDE AND EDUCT
BOOKS ARE IN LIBRARY
D WE THINK YOU SHOULD KNOW LAYL.
'S IMPORTANT NOT TO BE
DISCONNECTED, BUTO EMP
PARENTS.
R M NATIONAL GU
THE PANDEMIC.
SIONS ONREMASKS WERE NOT ALWAYP.
WEHAICHIGA
STATE FAIR.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OGO
SITUATION,E STATA BAD JOB,
DOWN.
>> DO LI DIX?
>> I, EVERYTHING EXCEPT TH
ABORTI